This episode is sponsored by Squarespace.
Go to Squarespace.com/microcosmos to save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or domain
Every time we see diatoms, we have to give
it to them: they’re just simply stunning.
They’re single-celled and major
producers of the oxygen we breathe,
but the real reason we love seeing
them is because of their frustules—
those silica shells they construct
for themselves to live in.
They’re architects building stained glass
walls to float in, and the effect is beautiful.
But apparently, diatoms are not content
to rest on their ornate laurels.
Because some don’t just
construct a home for themselves.
They construct a much larger structure
that houses a whole gathering of diatoms,
an apartment building made of one long tube.
Yes, a tube.
They’re really striking to look at, like pieces
of hay or strands of hair braided together.
The tubes we’re looking at
right now come from Iceland.
Our master of microscopes James sent his
assistant Ela there on a microbe hunt,
collecting samples from a
bunch of different places.
But they saved the marine samples for last because
those organisms tend to be
more delicate to handle.
So on this last collecting session,
James was on a video call, watching as
Ela scanned the dock she was standing on.
And along the submerged parts of the dock,
James spotted tufts of brownish
stuff peeking out as the waves broke.
So he asked Ela to grab some and bring them back.
The next day, she arrived at 6 am
and crashed on the couch, while James
immediately grabbed the samples to take a look.
And apparently, the entire time, he was saying,
“This is so beautiful.”
The samples that Ela brought back from
the dock were teeming with diatoms.
It might seem surprising that the waters
of Iceland can bring forth so much life,
especially during the cold and dark winter months.
But this matches James’ experience with the
ponds in Poland he gathers samples from,
which often end up dominated
by diatoms during the winter—
even as green algae numbers drop.
Diatoms seem to be fairly hardy in the dark.
One study found that diatoms survive longer than
flagellates in extended periods of darkness.
The researchers didn’t find a specific reason why
they’re able to tolerate the dark for so long, but
they theorized that perhaps the diatoms were more
conservative in how they managed energy reserves.
Others have also suggested that their
survival may be due to oils stored in
the diatoms, which may keep them better
stocked compared to other organisms.
Their survival in winter means
that when spring rolls around,
diatoms are often the first
groups to bloom in polar waters.
And perhaps these tube-like
structures are part of their success.
They’re not found as often in warmer waters,
but things are different when it gets cold.
In 1994, a scientist found a whole bunch of
these tubes along the Dutch coast in late winter.
And by a whole bunch, I mean there were more than
10 billion diatom cells living
in tubes, per square meter.
These tubular colonies start with
one diatom secreting a thread of
mucus from a pore, which it weaves into a tube.
Living in a mucus tube might not have
the same romantic feel as the diatom’s
stained glass shells, but diatoms
don’t have much need for romance.
As the tube gets longer and longer, the cell
reproduces asexually, dividing and populating
the tube with more cells like it so they can
travel through their shared home and add to it.
With every cell, a new roommate
and construction worker is added,
a cell that can strengthen and add
to the tube by producing more mucus.
At times, the cells might reproduce
faster than the tube can expand,
at which point they might start
to create a little side tunnel.
Their tube is a colony, and they
might end up attached to surfaces
like sand particles, or a submerged Iceland dock.
And they’re kind of similar to
colonies we’ve seen on this channel,
like Volvox and their spherical gatherings.
One thing that’s strange though is that based
on what little we know about these tubes,
it doesn’t seem as if these diatoms
do much to coordinate their activity.
This is different from volvox, where
various cells take on different functions,
and they work together to create
a better life for everyone.
But some of these diatoms act like they’ve
constructed a crowded city street just to
ignore each other, a group of co-workers who
don’t even say hi to each other in the hallway.
They’re little independent entities,
countless ships passing in the night.
And for those living in narrower
tubes, there’s no movement at all.
They’re simply stuck in place, next to
a family member they don’t acknowledge.
But there must be a reason they
live together in these tubes.
Otherwise, why bother with the time and
energy it takes to start making a tube,
and to keep adding to it.
The tube might be a form of protection,
making the diatoms too big for
microbial predators to consume.
But it’s probably also a way to help the diatoms
access light through a few different mechanisms.
To start, the tubes help lift the diatoms away
from the substrate they might have sunk to,
raising them towards any light
that might penetrate the water.
And as they float in the water,
the tubes allow the diatoms to
move with the rhythm of the waves,
illuminating all sides in the process.
At least, that’s one of the possibilities
for why these diatoms turn to tubes.
But stepping back from the “why,” it’s like
we’re starting to see more of who diatoms are.
They’re builders.
They may never have set out to become that,
but their approach to the world around
them has been to build, to assemble.
To make something functional and beautiful
even if the beauty is not the point.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to Squarespace
for sponsoring this episode.
Squarespace gives people a powerful and
beautiful online platform from
which to create their website.
So whether you’re looking to
create an online portfolio,
start a blog, or open an online
store, Squarespace can help you out.
Maybe it’s time for you to
take your Bookstagram to the
next level by starting a whole book-review blog!
Well, Squarespace has the tools you need.
They make it super simple to categorize,
schedule and share your blog posts.
And with Squarespace, you can
interact with your community
of fellow book lovers through
threaded comments and replies.
And if you decide you want to start
selling custom bookmarks and book sleeves,
Squarespace can help you out there as well.
Squarespace is already a powerful
ecommerce platform, but you can
even go the extra mile and add third-party
extensions to help you manage inventory,
streamline bookkeeping, and
ship products across the world.
And you can do all of this
on one easy-to-use platform.
So go to Squarespace.com to sign up for a
free trial, and when you’re ready to launch,
go to squarespace.com/microcosmos to save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or domain.
The names on the screen are our Patreon
patrons, these are the people who have
decided to directly support this channel
over at patreon.com/journeytomicro,
so we always want to take this time at the end
of our videos to thank them for their support.
If you want to see more from
our master of microscopes,
James Weiss, you can check out Jam
& Germs on Instagram and TikTok.
And you can also find Journey to the Microcosmos
on TikTok now if you want some Micro Microcosmos,
and if you want to see more
from us here on YouTube,
there is always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby.